hello freak [ __ ] but no I was saying
about dreams I would have liked when I
was detoxing like a [ __ ] booze
extravaganza and I would I would have
dreams that's why I was intrigued
because I would have [ __ ] crazy
dreams where I would be it would be so
lucid I went here brighter than the
storm right now I can say something that
was like a like a mixed version yeah
it's like I'm elevated on mushrooms like
DJ version so you detox I would do
Chuck's not have these dreams and they
were so lucid I'd be like walking around
the dream and I'll be and I knew would
know I was dreaming and I couldn't wake
myself up and I would try to wake myself
up so then I would try to like jump dive
out of a window to wake myself up or try
to like do something that will like jar
me awake and then I would do it and then
I would wake up and then I would be in
another [ __ ] dream to not be in my
bedroom and I'd be like I'm gonna go up
and get some water and then all of a
sudden realize oh my god I'm still in
the dream because this isn't the [ __ ] on
my walls and I'd have to wake myself up
again [ __ ] gnarly dude like you
psyched yourself out in the dream yeah I
gotta wake up like a.m. to wake up wake
up oh look you're awake yeah but it's
really just more training you're awake
[ __ ] yeah so that's I was kind of
fascinated by that it makes you wonder
what is real if you could live in a
perpetual dream what's going on there
you're still there's something happening
you're experiencing things it's things
are happening whether you're lying there
with your eyes closed or not there's a
bunch of [ __ ] that's going on a bunch of
experiences that your senses are taken
in that are pretty [ __ ] remarkably
similar to real life right like that's
why it's so crazy because it feels real
right that's why dreams like especially
lucid dreams trip you out because it
feels real it feels real but I liked it
just like when you dream like a really
weird Jimmy just accept the reality of
like like when I remember a drink Jane
you know be like yeah I just totally
XANA stream it just accepted that I was
like riding a rabbit you know I mean
like over a [ __ ] skyscraper that like
save Katy Perry's face or something you
know what was all except on my calves
one day look at that [ __ ] beer that's
fabulous
more sand people don't have beards back
then you
when he grew this beard the video is him
and a [ __ ] beautiful old Mustang
being a bad [ __ ]
yeah beards are like considered rogue
back there oh yeah he was I was he was
as rogue as it came man dude used to
pull dick out on stage went to jail for
it he's driving to the Tempe improv
right there I remember that he's gonna
go see Joey how do we know what really
goes on when you're asleep for eight
hours
how do we know when you're out cold when
you're calm you're out right how the
[ __ ] do we know what's actually
happening what's going on in these dream
states because you only remember a
fraction of the time you're out right
there's a fraction time
what if dreams aren't fake what if
they're just some alternative reality
that you occasionally intermingle with
when you're conscious or unconscious
rather like when you go into a dream
state maybe that's just like the shadow
of something that just happened that was
real maybe you have like these these
moments that seem like eight hours to
you or five hours to you but you're
really interfacing with some completely
different timeline and some completely
different reality and the world is
pliable it's not locked down like rocks
aren't rocks and water isn't water but
everything's fluid and changing
constantly and that's why when you're in
these dreams you freak out because all
of a sudden like the physics of reality
are gone you have like an that wall into
it maybe yeah well you might be a war
look just the fact that this world
exists in the state that it exists in
this world is very very bizarre right if
it wasn't real like this reality wasn't
real if we all lived in some sort of a
black-and-white print version of life
and then you got to experience the life
of you and I know that's doing stand-up
and being in LA and flying in planes and
using the Internet and experiencing life
in the 21st century in 2017 you would be
like this is the craziest psychedelic
trip if you went to Times Square right
would never you had never experienced
anything like human culture and you went
to Times Square
you would be freaking the [ __ ] out yeah
that'd be insane
it would be insane we're just so
just do it we're so used to it we don't
realize how bizarre the actual world is
well yeah I mean it possible that these
dream worlds that these are just
different worlds you tap into when you
conk out every night is a different
world B could be infinite could be
you're running a series of lives but you
have multiple lives going on and your
decisions you make in this conscious
life affect all of them and maybe you
have other lives when you're asleep
there are conscious when you're awake
but much like you're asleep and you
don't remember what the [ __ ] is going on
when they're asleep they don't remember
what the [ __ ] is going on and you
interface you might not just be nick
swardson stand-up comedian you might be
an entity that interfaces with multiple
different dimensions in the night and
you just don't remember it just like you
don't remember sleeping right you don't
remember dreaming you don't remember a
lot of [ __ ] that happens when you're
conked out for eight hours right well
they probably don't remember when you're
awake and you're interfacing you're not
just shutting off like your your brain
wants to everything needs to shut off so
that your other self in this other
dimension can interact and can go about
it's its world and maybe eight hours to
it is a month or a week to us we don't
even [ __ ] know maybe that's a huge
important part of being a person is that
other world has to have to coincide with
it maybe that's why Michael Jackson died
because they gave him that [ __ ] that
conked him out that didn't you don't
dream under that [ __ ] they would
basically put him under anesthesia every
night and you wouldn't get to interface
with the other world all right I got to
go no you never know I bet you got to I
I'm fascinated by dreams they're [ __ ]
are weird man but I mean yeah that maybe
they do mean something maybe there's
another most likely not I mean yeah I
think maybe just covered in spiders and
screaming I think that's basically well
you can be literal you work out stuff in
your dreams sometimes like you'll
experience I work out some but I don't I
don't work out ever hymns I never go to
the gym and dreams that's a good point
I've never [ __ ] ever worked out in a
dream I've never done that either that's
[ __ ] crazy
I just realized that I used to kick in
my dreams I used to like when I was
young especially I
girlfriends would complain I would like
twitch I'd like literally like throw a
kick I remember we build pair of meet
jokes about it like it sound like a
Bruce with Bruce Springsteen song
throwing kicks in the night it was like
an old ice house Chronicles we went on a
whole rant about it it was really really
strange thing so a lot of guys have that
problem like fighters have that problem
[Applause]
[Music]